take out from the bid and we're doing we
behind sings right now at the Mountain
Dew commercial and I'm about to do a
BuzzFeed to see what's me goes up imma
pick a ride and they see the lamborghini
truck or the rolls-royce phantom I'm
lost words the places disowned okay the
Bugatti the Lamborghini Aventador you
got the Maybach or the bin hmm so hard
decision let me see it
I think I go to me back it's a lot of
space in the Maybach you feel me I don't
really like a job so I tell my show
further you know I'm saying driving
around the city pick a beach vacation
Turks and Caicos Hawaii hide you
scrolling here Mexico or Brazil it's a
lot of beautiful ladies at each of those
locations I feel like God I got to go
stop by Mexico you feel me
cuz I am with me go go see my people man
it's only right pick a classic movie
next Friday dead presidents belly baby
boy
wrong way we having trouble bad boys to
pray before and they all like great
movies and you see what's fun I'm gonna
go with how am I gonna go with patron
for cuz I like that my I like to move it
cuz a lot of hustling going on and they
get money you did pick your favorite
single from culture to you see
motorsport stir-fry walkie-talkie and
North Pole's do I got a pick one that's
a hard decision
I'm gonna be buying not to golf or let
me see I got a pink one I was saying
narcos only reason why I'm
we had losing South Africa when we made
that a lot of Fighters good picking
orders to collaborate with goo up Dre
Callie I having a hard time scrolling
this up to chance what Travis Scott even
though he collaborated with artists I
still got a big one I got to go to my
boy walkman the feeling and I'm saying
one of my favorites one of the greatest
to me that's a song I'm gonna go up take
a place to eat in Atlanta junior cos
Waffle House clear my lounge busy bee
thumbs up or marry max I gotta go a busy
bee they have some good so hold over
that that's what I was not doing okay
so I got off set the coolest ice and
always remain calm and collected you're
unique and this helps you to stand out
you leave an imprint even with the light
touch and your star power there's
obvious because even with the small
ad-lib you can change an entire song
salute I'm saying if I broke me I got
some letters I'm sorry family so I got
set
[Music]